so I'm Toby software developer it's a
bad luck to talk to you about what we do
here and so on so that any further ado
let's jump into this talk the main just
at this is going to be our operational
experience that tap add actually using
aerospike i hijacked this deck from the
sales team so that's why it looks
beautiful insanity animations you can
see I that's why I correctly answered
the question okay so like I mentioned
work primarily going to talk about
aerospike there are a lot of different
components that go into the chat pod
technology stack that allows us to to
scale and do this cross device
technology effectively but aerospike is
a really really key component because
there are a number reasons that we're
all going to get into so I'm figured out
the animation you have actually every on
okay so we're gonna talk a little bit
more about what tap I've does
specifically with regards to adtech and
across device I think that we do why is
there might be a good fit for this we
have a very specific data model that one
yours probably experienced enough to
know that we select the right tool for
the right job general purpose database
will usually make you pretty far but
when you need to sort of push the limits
of performance need something a little
bit more specialized Paris pike fits
that very well for us will go into
couple anecdotes and more stories about
an operational experience and everyone
here will benefit from that and then a
few next steps these are things that tap
at is going to do in the near future
with regards to aerospike also have some
questions of the IMF anyone
has any okay so primarily what's
happened does is real-time bidding this
basically means that at any given time
when somebody opens up an appt they open
a web page there's going to be a message
sent from a cluster of servers to a
bitter system and that message is going
to contain information of where the
request is coming from and IP address
maybe some related information maybe
some demographic type of information or
some information that says this person
is interested in buying a car or
something like that it'll also be most
importantly some sort of identifier with
what it's usually going to be a cookie
ID for example or in Hardware I'd be
like an IDF a of an iphone and we need
to respond to this really quickly this
is all real time so we should we have
SSL ways of anywhere for 50 milliseconds
and upwards but our 95th percentile is
it varies from let's say 25 to 50
milliseconds depending on how much scale
we have so actually didn't realize that
this was animated before and it was
supposed to be in order conveniently
that does actually show our system much
better because it's it's incredibly
concurrent all these things are
happening it's a sequence e at the same
time so turned out better than I could
have imagined so so you have this ad
exchange it has some information that
there is a rectangle out there somewhere
on the web that's about to be filled in
with an ad and it's related to this
device a cookie ID 123 and send a
message over the top ad time I may say
okay we have no information on this
device we don't care about it just pass
it said the same thing on a device that
we do care about maybe this device is a
high value device because we have an
advertiser who wants to target people
with iphones and this request is coming
from my phone so we say yes but you know
we want to buy it they display the ad
and everything's good so then 30
milliseconds is more or less the average
which is more than sufficient it's
usually much much faster but
average of time and shawl time and this
is how often that we do it so this
results in Billings requests per second
it's not easy to hit that much scale oh
so the 30 milliseconds is our 95th
percentile latency once a big request
hits the system that we get a response
back out so does not include the transit
time over you know someone else's
network it's just when it hits our
system and then when we respond but this
includes parsing the data looking up
from air strikes and information on the
device couplings of logic how much money
do we have to spend do we have tracking
information that makes us interesting
device or not formatting response and
writing it back to the output string and
now that's that's a cut off so the
question was where does any procedure
take place in our system they're
actually two primary places so we will
have an internal option from any any
number of different tactics that are
running all may be interested in the
same device everyone bids highest bidder
wins we send our response back with a
single price that will go into an
auction on the ad exchange and then we
may or may not win there the second
price option the part of the ladies
aerospike doesn't doesn't actually touch
the option system it's just looking
things up based on that better that key
which is the device ID ok so why her
lake it's really fast and we're going to
get into some bumpers later but our use
case is very read heavy key value lookup
era spike just demolishes as it was
elated competitors it's safe for a
couple different reasons we're going to
that basically replication and things
RSS feed back it's not just data that's
in memory linear scalability you add
more notes you get more performance and
then there are a couple features in
Harris fight specifically expiration and
which are somewhat related that are
really really useful when you're in the
ad tech world this database was created
by engineers who are in ad tech and
that's why we have the we're able to
take advantage of these specialized
features that may not be as important in
the more generalized database okay so
under cluster right now we're getting
about 350 k reads for a second at peak
times you may note that this number is
different than the 250 k I showed
earlier because any given bid request
may actually trigger multiple reads from
the database that will primarily happen
because we have multiple IDs from
different partners that already sent the
same device so we have a thing called an
alias you look up device one two three
and maybe you don't actually get the
device yet you see that it's actually
reference to something else follow the
chain down make another read then you
end up with the device record and as you
can see here from from all the
promotional materials we actually do see
in production that yes ninety-nine
percent of these threes are under a
millisecond we can hit the graded
service sometimes for a variety of
reasons but by and large the performance
is fantastic and this is books from
contact over here who made this chart
and this basically shows air flights
performance through put on an SSD fact
data sets and pretty much shows the
number series its difficulty faster than
some competitors into space so let
mentioned before we're very very read
heavy so we're doing 350,000 reads per
second and on the other side we're doing
probably about 30,000 writes per second
so it's very tailored one way and
conveniently that is the one word I
should performs even better
ok so it's also safe we use their swag
as a primary database it's not a catch
but it does have some similar
characteristics to things like memcached
which is only in membrane so notes go
down your data is not there anymore you
can configure aerospike to operate in
this manner with an in-memory only
storage but the way our setup is we have
one hundred percent of our keys and
indexes in memory and then we have one
hundred percent of the records in stored
on disk this is really convenient
because we actually have incredibly
consistent read and write performance
which is great we have tried some other
databases earlier that because of
caching will sometimes be really really
really fast and then all of a sudden
performance drops off a cliff because
some of your data is not a member
anymore and you have to add s this is
slower and everything starts logging
down since on all our reads we are
actually hitting this it's still very
fast but it's very consistent as well ok
good Michael an order their replication
factor so you automatically get
replication with aerospike user
replication factor of two this means if
a note goes down the data is still
available and the middle one this one is
really handy frost data center
replication it's fantastically simple to
set up and it works very well so we have
two data centers in the US one of these
coasts one of the West you send an
update to the west coast data center
it's going to here on the east coast
datacenter milliseconds later
okay so scalability the dream of
everything is linear scalability and
that works extremely well Paris pike at
a node and your performance will
increase linearly for reads and for
writes the caveat is that it's not magic
there are still some operational
concerns to pay attention here we'll get
into that a little bit more later but
basically when you add that note it's
empty and has no data but it's running a
cluster that has potentially many
terabytes of data it needs to do some
heavy rewrite operations in order to
figure out what data to drop a to itself
so it will affect cluster performance so
of course it's much easier to tell key
value the key value stored linearly than
something like a relational database
that's completely fine it's not cheating
or anything like that this fits our data
model perfectly okay so for these
special characteristics expiration and
eviction are really handy for adtech in
EdTech so all data is important let's
say but fresher data is significantly
more important so aerospike has
facilities could set a TTL on a record
and then once that TTL is reached
there's a supervisor thread for the
namespace is basically database and it
will find the old records and chuck them
leaving your board space for adding new
data and so the eviction policy is kind
of similar where if you enter a
situation where you're actually running
out of storage space you need to write
but there's no space there's like we'll
look at the oldest stuff in other words
thing to the shortest TTL it'll start
checking those out because those are
theoretically the lowest value because
they're about to expire anyway just
accelerate that exploration process and
this allows your system to continue
running with the amazing slowly degraded
performance because you are dropping
data but the whole system has ever keep
running and that's really valuable to
have that resilience so quick how many
people here are a mantic
okay so that's that's the vast majority
so ready to go into this anymore new
data is more valuable okay so that was
sort of the interim or those of you who
have not gettin easier spike those
features are absolutely fantastic and
you can read all about that from any
number of blogs promotional material air
sites web site has some fantastic white
papers but now here we are the trenches
are actually running a saying what has
happened so for configuration this is
what topics deployments actually looks
like so you know one difference for
example we don't have as many guests as
the sounds from eros lights benchmarks
because our setup it's every bit of my
demo storage but we'll add a couple
notes on that for migrations what really
happens when you add a note to the
cluster or you remove a node can't
imagine where ever actually going to
reduce storage but we're certainly going
to continue increasing storage a little
bit more about eviction that was a
fantastic feature as still as a pathetic
feature we rely on it there's a very
sort of counterintuitive gotcha that we
encountered and tell the story about
that one meant for usage as a software
developer how do you actually use this
thing what does the experience like
interacting to the state basis it's
simple what kind of clients do you have
to use they already written for you and
so on
but they've got a lot of time soon okay
so big data has all sorts of different
definitions we attack i have a decent
amount another number isn't there by the
way so we have something like 3.3
billion objects in a cluster right now
representing multiple terabytes and load
it to this earlier before we have all
the keys in memory all the data on
storage now since you ever pick you back
up to let's say we have one terabyte of
data you have two terabytes of disk but
then there's another consideration this
is a high-water mark you need a lot of
contiguous free disk space in order for
aerospike to perform can compaction and
different agents of a graph which and so
the recommended number for this is fifty
percent which means you should have
fifty percent memory available free at
all times just to perform this operation
and fifty percent of this this is quite
a lot so we decided to so push the
limits a little bit and we set these
high watermarks to two seventy percent
on memory and storage just doesn't save
us a little bit of money on on hardware
as ryan contesta we like running lean so
that's great and everything but it's
possible to send updates to our spike
actually at a rate faster than the deep
fryer can keep up especially when you
change the recommended configuration to
a seventy percent high watermark so that
is you happen to us and this led to an
out of this space situation even though
we actually have forty percent of the
disk free so we're trying to send rights
era spikes not happy gal the space on
disk what the heck do we do so the
solution in this case was to actually
change the high-water mark down to sixty
percent from 70 this led the database
this law on purpose but the database
destructive
sooner that's all this old data gets
okay chucked out we now era spike knows
that it actually has much more free
space available we have that contiguous
free space to use for defragment and
we're back in business and it's now
still on sixty percent so far so good
okay I didn't really talk about this
cycle lot size yet we're going to get
fat a little bit more later again but
basically that's the commitment size for
a block read so the key points it some
data to read 512 bytes one way or
another at least okay so this is
actually very relevant to that block the
block size this is a graph of objects in
aerospike based on 128 bytes pins so I
mentioned earlier that we have 3.3
billion objects the records themselves
are really small most of them are about
200 bytes or so now here we can see a
pretty chiming Lee even distribution of
the numbers the number of objects in
increasing size bins this is one crazy
outlier up there and that's in between
128 bytes and 256 bytes that's what the
majority of our records are so what this
actually needs in practices when we
write a you know 200 biting record when
we read we only need those subjects but
we're actually reading back 512 bytes so
this is willing wasted wasteful we might
be wasting fifty percent maybe plus on
that particular storage this has been
fixed in version 27 and 31 so you can
actually have a minimum lot size of 128
bytes so this is going to be great for
our storage and where we're really
looking forward
getting back in this appointment
okay so migrations and partitions what
is this well migration is basically when
you add a new node to the cluster you
have to migrate data off the cluster
into this new node and that actually
means that you're going to run into some
degraded performance because the node
has to do a bunch of work probably
significantly more work than your normal
workload might actually present so in in
our experience we've seen that adding it
in go to the cluster could be
potentially up to 24 hours of degraded
performance this means this is some it
still working pretty well maybe our
reads are two milliseconds or four
milliseconds instead of one but this is
also somewhat to the bull so you can
have a note join the cluster much more
slowly which means many fewer reads and
writes for that to join and then you're
going to see in a very little
degradation or you get in sort of crank
it up to 11 and migrate really that much
much faster and the cluster will see
flora performance the network partition
can trigger the same events as actually
removing the cluster you can't
necessarily tell we've seen when the
longer the part of the network partition
the more data migration is going to
happen and the more degradation you're
going to see across the cluster to be
honest I don't understand it all that
well but you know generally it will
repair itself and you may have no
degradation you may have few minutes
maybe three hours of the greatest
service but eventually the kind of
running
okay so I promise you a little bit of a
story about this eviction situation and
I so here it is to recap eviction is
basically a fast-forward of an
expiration policy if you are hitting
your limit on storage and you're
continuing to try to write to the
database there are couple failure
options the traditional database will
probably just reject the rights era
spike will try to keep that fresh data
and we'll look in the oldest data and
start checking that early the way it
does this is based on the TTL of the
record so this is my beautiful artwork
here and it shows objects on one side
that are going to expire pretty soon and
then over here objects are going to
stick around for very long time in
practice these numbers were 13 months
for this bucket and then for the other
bucket where we have the vast majority
of Records sort of like 30 days and
literally nothing in between the way the
eviction buckets are created is by
looking at the smallest and the largest
TTL times chopping them up into even
buckets and then putting the records
into those buckets in this case there's
not an even distribution whatsoever as
you can see the majority of our data was
in is low CTL bucket which is the one
that is going to get evicted from once
you're in that bucket air cycle I think
it's randomly or maybe not now but
apparently randomly shut something from
the bucket now if you have even
distribution TTL this is completely fine
as fantastic as what you want when
things are not distributed well it's
going to appear as though data is
randomly being evicted this is really
really confusing for us once you figure
out what the problem was we realize that
we needed to get an even distribution of
our records and these TTL buckets so
eviction will work properly so the old
bucket will actually represent the
oldest things
set of everything so we simply did a job
but took all these records with a very
high TTL change it to exactly the same
as the other records TT Ellison we just
have this other job that will have cycle
through and continuously refresh those
objects and that's been working for us
okay so as a user of the system software
developer what what does it like we use
the Java client and it's pretty simple
straightforward the software sack here
at tap add is solemn from the ground up
so we have a simple wrapper around the
Java client works perfectly there's now
a blue the native scallop clients but we
have been using that one yet starts
working pretty well and there's now also
a non-blocking client that's available
and it's further performance we have a
bottom client used in most of our
systems and the non-blocking clients is
still we're still rolling it out across
different systems with performing really
well our records themselves are LZ for
compressed protocol buffers cemetery
familiar with protocol buffers yeah most
people was expected so this is a
serialization format Google came out a
bit giggly we defined a SEMA you know
integers strings various other data
types and throw to get in there we'll
have a pro buffer portable tool
generates a foot for you in this case
java and then to see realises it to some
fights we compress those fights with lz4
and we saw that as the record inside our
site and the key for the majority of the
data we had an irish life is going to be
some sort of device identifier like a
cookie ID another thing I thought we
sort of actually to throw in here is a
hotkey error that will see our logs
periodically so basically you cannot get
away from having hot spots and data and
a hockey error will be thrown by the
clients by default when there are three
outstanding breeds for the same key and
it's not really a problem for us
whatsoever it's just kind of something
to notes that you're getting a lot of
reasons ink
do maintenance work it's like the way
our workload actually pans out things
are very well distributed across all the
data but a hockey error is usually
negative of some other sort of systemic
problem where there is one ID that's
being referred to by also the things
that probably attend judge you for it to
do something else so this would be a bad
idea safe for example where we are have
merged many different devices into one
device and so now we continue what thing
that went up in that you should be
bitten once
okay so what's next two-top add an arrow
spider well one thing we really really
want to do is what I mentioned earlier
is getting upgrade in so we can use a
smaller minimum lot size this will save
something like fifty percent of our
storage because we don't need a
five-fold middle block size and use the
128 block size yeah so we also have read
us in our system which we use primarily
for budget counters right us has this
atomic increments operation so you have
a key which is an integer and you say
okay prevent this thing by a thousand
surely handy but at our scale we're
doing so many rights that registers
actually not particularly performance
and it doesn't have the same clustering
and cross data center replication
facilities at aerospike does so verra
spike does support UDF the user-defined
functions you write them in Luang and
you can perform some sort of operation
actually on the earth select server you
don't need to have application code that
makes a request gets a response doesn't
update and then makes it right so we're
going to explore it in your future is UD
asset base it just takes initiative type
performs an atomic update and you just
need one single request and it'll be
faster than res and then finally I don't
know if this on the pipeline or anything
but one request we would love to have
multiple keys that can actually point
same data record what we had yes when we
want to show the numbers of the 250,000
bid requests per second resulting in
something like 350 thousand degrees for
secondary one of the main drivers of
that is following an alias chain but may
have a device ID which is devices number
one it points to another record which is
not actually a device but an alias to
another device so by side be one once
the device ID to which is the canonical
ID and then that ID points to the record
which contains the device so we could
have this key one and key to both went
to the same record will be able to save
a lot of performance and that's that's
it so thanks very much for coming we've
got time for questions but your way
right
is
how much
my office
is the infection the question was does
the does evicting threat never at fault
line and if it does I guess sort of how
do you how do you catch up well I mean
the process is not free no Brian you
want to take this one yeah wine is our
head of operations by the way he does
much more batters question I did there
are
and while
okay go for it
what happened
Oh
the question was what happens when you
get a hot key error it's up to your
application really the hot key error is
generated by the client itself and the
number three reeds outstanding is some
configurable value it's really just an
indicator to your application that's
there are many reads where three equates
to many happening at the same time so
it's really just an indicator it's not
actually an error you clean they're
still getting the data back is fine but
you need to be aware that you may end up
in a race condition where you know the
classic race condition where you have
let's say three plans they all read the
data they'll make their independence and
right back err slight can't solve that
for you need to figure out how to deal
with that on your own concern library
slightly
one
check your records
he segregated them
sure so the question was to elaborate a
little bit on why we have our
configuration you say what you repeat
what I said to ask right ok so the
configuration that we have is one of
multiple that you can have with era
spike where we have the namespace which
is essentially a database and a respite
configure to keep all the keys in memory
and all the data on disk and we have
this because we want the consistent re
performance where we're not going to
have any cache data everything is going
to be looked up very fast under a
millisecond having that consistency and
performance makes it so easy to decide
or to figure out how much it's going to
cost if you want to scale out there are
no mysteries some of our database
systems that rely more extensively on
cashing can make that a little bit
tricky because if you have hot data in
memory excuse me that's fantastic people
read it very quickly but once you get
this things sort of fall over so you may
actually need to get many more new
servers that you may otherwise have
expected because of this consistency you
know that you have one knows you're
going to get exactly the performance you
expect there are other configurations so
you can have an entirely new memory
storage which is like traditional liquor
memcache sort of setup where your keys
and data are all in memory and there is
no durability you can also have SSD back
in memory where the data is never ate
but then it so persisted to this behind
the scenes good answer question
so you guys used features in ours
so we're not on sorry the question was
simply use user mind functions which are
a feature of air strike three the answer
is we're not an heiress 53 yet so no we
have not used them but one of the things
in the 1x4 with the UDF is to have
things like atomic and comment
operations and scripting the moolah Sin
City pretty simple they will be
straightforward but I don't have any
practical experience together
No
the question was we have discussed
datacenter replication operating to the
east and west coast what happens in to
the network partition where the
operational concerns so sure network
partitions definitely happen the transit
provider might have a lip and we won't
be able to replicate for for a little
while it'll basically just pick up after
after partition kills itself it's not
really that much more to it's sort of
magical magical scaling sprinkles around
doing anything
also
that keeps a lot
so while they're writing locally and
network
havin right there degeneration bridge
the replication treatment
he's rebuilt directly
Jerry told that
decorating they are a veteran sector
seven
Frank all that
votes on here but actually equal
that is right she actually write the
same time and it'll accidental
so 3 be a little too that for the
cameras and for the posted in here it's
a generational system that but each
circle apps have notice how which rights
have been actually propagated across and
also xcr across native replication is
totally master so you just write
anywhere i can change its propagated so
the question was at any given time once
the ratio reach the rights very roughly
ten to one correct Henry's right
so the question is can you configure a
timeout to the clients and what's the
percentage of time else so yes you can
configure the client to timeout it or
whatever timeout you want so for us we
can put a couple milliseconds and there
we have some batch jobs where we
actually crank up the time out to even
even second sometimes we don't want any
timeouts whatsoever but the percentage
of timeouts is completely dependent on
your client configuration and how much
activity your cluster is getting so you
can imagine that if you have time out
sets of one millisecond and your cluster
supporting 99% of REITs under
milliseconds then you'll have one
percent timeouts
innovation of day
why
question was do we use any or rely on
any relational databases and yeah the
answer is yes aerospike is one part one
very significant part of the system but
we also have my sequel restoring various
transactional data and sort of
configuration types of things Russell
use vertical as our analytics sequel
database as a column on games
column-oriented store and speaks equal
to it it's pretty simple got a five
million system now storing on many
terabytes which is a great tool for the
right job sort of distinction where
Harris wife is it certainly fast for
that for that synchronous request
response cycle we needed these were fast
n licks on vertica and these things to
need seconds or minutes long queries
that are generating sort of batch jobs
they don't need to be particularly fast
screens a to do so
anyone else
alright thanks so much really appreciate
it there are a bunch of Eros like quotes
around if you want to talk to them and
again come up to me there's also tap out
is around and got practical experience
and plenty of food and beer left some
ourselves thank you